i had a very good relationship with
president xi
i would even say better than good i
would say we had a great relationship
uh he's a great gentleman but my
relationship
is no longer very good with him because
of what they did with the china virus
so as tensions between the united states
and china escalate our secretary of
health and human services
sat down with taiwan's president this
was the highest level meeting
between our two countries in decades
china considers taiwan to be a sovereign
part of china
and firmly opposes any official
interactions
between the united states and taiwan so
in answer to this meeting china sent
fighter jets over this over the site of
that meeting
to send a very clear message joining me
now is health and human services
secretary alex azar fresh
uh off of his historic trip he's still
there in fact he's heading back shortly
uh secretary azar thank you very much
for being here so
clearly china thinks that your visit was
a provocative move what do you say to
them
well as secretary of pompeo said
yesterday the chinese communist party
has to be feeling pretty weak and
insecure if the visit of a health
secretary to meet with
other health colleagues in the middle of
a pandemic to an area like taiwan that
has been a model of transparency and
openness and democratic values
throughout this
somehow uh threatens them enough to send
fighter jets
um you know i mean you know to their
in understanding they do not recognize
that taiwan is a separate country
and you're meeting with them with the
president not just the health and
services
secretary this was the highest level
meeting
in decades from the united states to
taiwan
so what was the message and also you
know said the president sends strong
support
uh for taiwan and china said that your
visit
endangered peace well my visit is
completely consistent with the us's
long-standing one china policy
and is completely consistent with the
press president of
senior level engagement between the
united states and representatives
of taiwan what the communist party of
china should be more focused on
is getting more transparent more open
more collaborative on covet 19
when they brought this upon us by
concealing so much about this virus in
its origins
as well as the nature of the disease and
preventing international observers in
throughout and as i said in the speech
yesterday here in taiwan
if this virus had emerged in taiwan or
in the united states an open democratic
transparent public health system
we could have stopped it in its tracks
well i think everybody wishes that that
was what happened the language that you
just used in that response
that the united states continues to
uphold the one china policy is obviously
the phrase that china
is looking to hear uh that is the policy
that they
insist upon from everybody that does
business with china essentially
and yet we know that that taiwan is
concerned
that china might make even aggressive
military moves against the country that
you're in right now
uh we've also seen this national
security policy in hong kong
and how that's playing out people are
getting arrested and pulled out of
newspaper offices so why do we still
have a one china policy
given what you just said about china's
behavior
with this virus well i'm going to focus
on health issues and uh you know
one of the things that we've seen is
when president tsai was
elected here in as part of a vibrant
democratic
process in taiwan four years ago she was
first elected
the chinese communist party went to the
world health organization and said
taiwan can no longer participate in
observer status which had
done for years they bullied the who
they bullied taiwan they kicked taiwan
out and
the trump administration and i and
secretary pompeo
have been fighting to get taiwan back in
so that
taiwan can contribute with their
excellent public health system that
they've got the transparent information
they can provide
you know they're one of only two
entities on earth macau
and taiwan that the state department and
cdc now have a level one
the lowest level travel advisory for
they've done such a great job
dealing with covet 19 unlike china
yeah i mean the reason that china
doesn't want them represented in the who
among other things is that they don't
consider them a country
um so it seems like those two things are
at odds to say that we still have a one
china policy
but to also say that you want chi you
want taiwan as a separate
entity to be part of all of these
international organizations because we
so respect
their democracy and the way they've
handled this
well i think they'd also be embarrassed
by the transparency and effectiveness of
the public health system here
um taiwan had participated in observer
status
for years but then the communist party
decided that that was no longer
acceptable
and bullied and sought to exclude you
know uh back in 2018 this is how bad it
is in 2018
there was an ebola outbreak in western
democratic republic of the congo
yeah the who asked for emergency
contributions
china had not provided any taiwan
offered a million dollars
and what did the communist party of
china do they bullied
and required the who to reject that
million-dollar donation no strings
attached from taiwan to help
the democratic republic of the congo
prevent an ebola outbreak that's how
thuggish they've been
well uh yeah and i think that speaks to
the the big picture and the president
uh has acknowledged that that
relationship has changed i know you're
uh
you're heading back soon and i hope when
you get back you'll join us again
because we want to talk about the
vaccine
uh as well which we hear is in the works
and going to roll out in december and
russia's vaccine as well
so we'll talk about that next time
secretary thank you very much secretary
azar good to have you with us tonight
thank you martha